Now, as I already said, half the country and
99 percent of the world breathed a huge sigh
of relief that Donald Trump is being removed
from office strongly and powerfully being
removed.
And plenty of people, understandably, are
exhausted from the last four years and they're
looking to tune out of politics now for a
while.
This is not the time to do it.
And in fact, this is when the activism can
start.
We will be talking about the Georgia Senate
races.
Control of the Senate has not yet been decided.
We have two special elections on January 5th
that will decide control of the Senate.
But this is much bigger than that now is when
you have to get to work to, number one, undo
the disasters of Trump.
And number two, more importantly, we have
to do stuff.
We on the left believe that government should
do some things.
The right has the structural advantage because
one of their ideas is government shouldn't
be doing anything.
Now, of course, if they need to ban gay marriage,
all of a sudden they should be doing something
if they need to ban abortion.
But other than when they're hypocrites, their
idea is get government out.
They win by preventing government from doing
anything.
Now is when we have to start trying to put
points on the board.
I've used this analogy before.
We've been playing defense while Donald Trump
has been president.
They've had the ball.
We've gotten the ball back by having Joe Biden
win.
But Biden may not have the Senate and simply
getting Trump out doesn't win.
We will be discussing Biden's plans for day
one executive orders shortly.
And that list has to grow.
But the real systemic changes won't come through
executive orders.
They will come through legislation, tax reform,
climate policy, health care, education, coronavirus
relief.
These things will happen through legislation.
And without Senate control, it will be really
tough, which means, number one, we must be
laser focused for the next two months on the
Senate races.
And number two, this is the time to engage.
So I'm not underselling Biden's win.
It's huge.
Removing an incumbent president is really
tough.
But I want to remind you, Biden's win is the
prerequisite to being able to be activists
for policy.
During the Trump presidency, we were activists
for removing Trump to stop the bleeding and
preventing him from doing more damage.
Now we actually have to be activists for doing
the work of getting things done.
I was stunned and inspired that we had during
our our late last week streams.
And over the weekend, about a thousand new
members sign up on our website with the coupon
code Fresh Start, the idea being we are now
at the start.
It's a new start and an important one at that.
This is how progress is made.
You think to the big progressive eras, the
three big areas of progressive change, the
progressive era of 1890 to 1920, the New Deal
era towards the end of World War Two, the
civil rights era of the late fifties into
the sixties.
The presidential elections were merely the
beginnings.
They were the prerequisites.
But the successes depended on voting and voting
again and again, and on protests and activism,
walkouts and sit ins, lobbying elected officials,
getting the right people on the Supreme Court.
Sometimes activism requires pushing cases
through courts higher and higher through the
appeals process.
And right now we certainly don't have.
The Supreme Court, so the point is, we're
tired, the last four years have been exhausting,
we have two months now with a really simple
focus.
Get the two Senate seats in Georgia will then
have a sort of two week break.
And then Joe Biden is inaugurated and the
real work starts.
I hope you'll be with me for it.
Let me know on Twitter at David Pakman what
you believe the focus should be